hey guys it's ANCA so I'm in Taipei
right now and I want to show you guys
just how awesome 7-eleven hereit's
today's challenge is for me to make a
three-course meal I'm excited I hope
you're excited too let's go and give it
a shot so the local 7-eleven stores in
Taipei are actually very different from
the ones in America there are actually
more like cafes people come here to hang
out or to have business meetings over
here they also have a lot more products
and services that we didn't even know
7-eleven could possibly have oh I don't
think so I live I would sell illusion
they have a lot of products here first
aid area in terms of toiletries even dog
food and cat food here we have the ramen
section and there's obviously a lot of
chips wait we shouldn't get distracted
by it I'm gonna start doing this so for
appetizers and should probably get some
bread purely because the friend here
looks amazing I am a hundred percent
getting this garlic bread maybe we could
get some steamed eggs that looks really
good we are getting fried chicken
there's also salad here but there's beef
noodle soup
so cold noodles which is what I'm gonna
get today I'm also gonna get this lunch
box I think I'm gonna add an egg to the
rice to make it extra special for heart
random picking this pretty popular milk
tea that they have here in terms of code
drinks there's a lot here but I think
I'm gonna get the bubble tea
here we have the first the second course
there is a lot of stuff this is going to
be a really big meal let's do it
I'm going to start off with the bubble
tea you can see the layer of boba here
and then there's milk
we're going to mix that together it
looks pretty legit this is actually not
milk tea it's a brown sugar milk drink
which is also really good just that it's
a little um a sweeter side I think they
did pretty good even though I would say
in Taipei I'd probably go buy this drink
somewhere else next we have this garlic
bread it looks like a golden brick of
garlicky goodness it's so thick maybe
it's because there's garlic butter on
all six sides but the garlic flavor
really comes out the bread has a nice
firmness to it which is probably why
it's holding that garlic butter so well
this is so good 100% recommend so now
we're gonna go into the steamed egg you
can see a jiggle there's corn in there
chicken
edamame looks pretty good to me it's a
very healthy hot food item this is
really smooth with the lightest touch it
kind of just falls apart on a cold
winter night this would be the go-to
snack our last food item for our first
course is this taiwanese fried chicken a
very popular street food again not
something i think people would expect to
find at 7-eleven what we do need to do
though is to microwave this and
so we might crave the chicken this is
what it looks like on the inside wow
this looks so good and it smells so good
there's only six pieces in here I need
to eat a second one for better analysis
it does taste a little soggy er which
makes a lot of sense because we
microwave this but the flavor of this
chicken on point definitely like better
quality than I would expect to find here
at a convenience store I think that
concludes our first course now let's
move on to the second course we have
noodles we have a bento box we have buns
soft boiled eggs which will go with the
rice and then we have a hot drink I'm
going to start us off with the cold
noodles probably one of my favorite
things to get every time I'm here in
Taipei there's sesame sauce soy sauce
based noodle sauce and then we have
cucumbers to drizzle that over now we're
gonna mix it together I already know
this is going to be good if you asked me
about the top thing I would recommend
here at 7-eleven this is it the flavor
of the sauces the texture of the noodles
even the freshness of the cucumber and
look at this portion size there's so
much then its shape is so good so our
other main dish for today is in pork
chop bento box I've actually never had
this before so I'm very excited to try
it for the first time
[Music]
after your microwave this
it's SuperDuper hot so what they do is
give you this little bag that you can
put it in so you don't burn your fingers
it's so cute look at the beautiful sauce
a little egg underneath a little
vegetable side dish and more vegetables
on this side with a little river jelly
what I'm gonna do now is put this in
with the rice there's two little eggs
that is beautiful
this is soft-boiled I've done right now
I'm gonna put this on the rice so this
is the final product this giant piece of
pork and to it all in all I would say
this is pretty standard definitely would
pull you up this is still my favorite
part though this little bag
I'm genius I'm gonna take a sip of this
drink classic milk tea drink what I like
most about this they actually have like
a hot fringe here to store all these
drinks which is perfect for when it gets
cold in winter one more thing for our
second course meal the bun so there's
kimchi mixed inside of this pork the bun
is soft and fluffy there's actually
quite a bit of filling honestly tastes
like something you would be able to buy
at a restaurant
I've already had way too much food but
we have one more course left and that's
dessert which I'm gonna go get now I'm
gonna try and keep it simple but I don't
know no promises
[Music]
okay so I told myself not to get too
carried away let me explain it just
looks super cool I've never seen
anything like this is is an ice cream
mochi you think there's actually crowned
king bits in this chocolate Boston pie
if she just looks from really good grape
jelly because it's huge so I had to get
it
crepe ice cream it's like a drumstick
but in a crepe mmm so it really is just
ice cream with chocolate bits on the
inside you can see the little flakes on
top and the creep is actually it's soft
like you would expect a fresh crepe to
be look at this I love it I love that
they have this here I should stop i'ma
stop now for this one little mochi ice
cream even comes with a little spoon
thing hold on this is what it looks like
on the inside they're all great ice
cream that's what it tastes like a mochi
is chewy this is a dessert that I would
come back and have again next up we have
the grape jelly super excited whoo look
at this it's so juicy you can see the
little like grape fits in here this is
like a fresh fruit jelly the grapes
aren't actually really good if you want
something light and something fruity
this is a great dessert to have and it's
huge you could split this between three
people okay maybe two last dessert item
oh here is that chocolate Boston pie the
Boston cream pie I think is known for
its thick cream filling this is a
chocolate version of that and it smells
really good this cream is more like a
chocolate mousse the chocolate flavor
here is so rich I can't believe this
isn't something at a bakery I am so
amazed right now that conclude
our three-course meal at 7-eleven or
maybe more like ten course meal you can
get everything from appetizers to main
courses to desserts right here at the
same spot it's almost like a picker own
style buffet and now I think I'm done
with eating for the week that was a lot
[Music]